[Music]
tyler in north dakota
tyler says i've been dating this girl
for three years
and she was never taught about money
growing up so i've tried to teach her
over the last few years
she just had her come to jesus moment
and wants to change but she recently
lost her job and now she can't afford
rent for this next month i make decent
money and i'm pretty far ahead
should i lend her 350 dollars so she can
try and come out on her feet or should i
walk let
should i watch and let her learn from
her mistakes
no you don't lend money okay if you
good answer been dating for three years
so this is a tricky one dave because
they've been together
for three years if he wants to give her
some money
um three years is a long time that's an
invested relationship i don't personally
like that either
when you start bailing out your
boyfriend or girlfriend that can get
messy
short-term man long-term but three years
if he said we were engaged we were gonna
get married that's one thing but
man this feels this feels like a
slippery slope and a messy mess if you
ask me
what do you think dave uh well i i agree
with you
uh so explain what you mean
like this is going to change the it's
going to change the tone of their
relationship
yeah i mean just reading through this
question um
his job isn't to try and teach the
person that he loves unless she's asking
for it and she's interested in some of
these moments and
i've been guilty of trying to quote
unquote try and teach my wife some
things over the years that
after 15 20 years together i realized oh
she was way ahead of me on those things
right she was bobble heading here right
and obviously you never lend somebody
that you care about no
no no no no no no no no no no no you
just don't lend people money period
when you're dating somebody and you give
them money you give he gives her 350
bucks he gives her 500 bucks
the power dynamic of this relationship
suddenly she's beholden to him even
though he's gonna give it to her
and let's just say that he is a
perfectly noble
guy and has zero
negative power feelings toxic power
feelings about giving her the money he
just gave it to her and he's just he's a
great guy and he's no big deal
the water off a duck's back but the way
she feels she's going to take that
she could change with shame that's
exactly she feels beholden and i'll tell
you right now he's not dave he's
somebody
that's gonna use this opportunity to
teach her and to give her some lessons
and to give her some information and man
he's just you're setting up your
relationship
for a mess yeah and so the only way it's
you're gonna pull it off is you're going
to say all these things out loud that's
exactly right
and you have to go the problem with me
doing this
is it could end up with this and this
and this and this and this and we can't
have that
so i'm giving you this money there is no
strings i'm not going to teach you or
talk to you or whatever and you can't
you can't act like weird after this
that's right
you can't change you know you've got to
just be normal you got to just pretend
like the transaction didn't
happen and uh you don't owe me anything
nope you don't owe me a bowed head you
don't
owe me honor you don't owe me
uh the money back uh you don't owe me
sexual favors you don't owe me
anything right and you just got to
really say
all of this out loud because when you
say it out loud it go
it leaves the room it loses its power on
yeah right when you're shining the light
on the room the roaches run out that's
exactly right
and i might sit her down and say would
you be interested in
in this because if i sometimes my gift
to you can be a burden for somebody else
right
if you're having this kind of
conversation you need to put i love that
put it all on the table
and then ask would you be willing to
accept this again and before you put it
on the table just go this is awkward as
crap it's super weird if you say
something's awkward before it's awkward
it's less awkward every time that's
exactly right yes
so yeah this is going to be weird yeah
we even do that with difficult
conversations inside this building all
the time we go
look it's going to be a difficult
conversation as soon as you say that
it changes the room and safe and it's
less difficult i've had several people
have to tell me that since i've worked
here
this is going to be weird it's going to
be one of those weird conversations
that involves you that's not true but
it's a good joke i love it